[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les stars qui s'insultent sur les
réseaux sociaux ça part dans tous les
sens ça devient très vulgaire c'est en
règle des comptes
est-ce qu'il faut intervenir ou pas vous
trouvez ça pathétique ou sincère
regarder on en parle après les réseaux
sociaux c'est l'endroit au monde où il
ya le plus de bruit juste avant les
embouteillages et la ville à des
marseillais contre les ch'tis il faut
dire que c'est facile de dire ce qu'on
pense qu'en son nom est un pseudo et que
sa photo de profil un oeuf
mais il n'ya pas que les internautes
mystère qui s'insultent sur les réseaux
les célébrités elle même n'échappe pas à
cette règle
comme il ya nakamura qui s'est
embrouillé avec matt petit coup même
chose pour rémi gaillard qui lui aussi a
perdu son sang froid pour matthieu
delormeau l'animal n'a pas conscience
qu'il va mourir
est ce que vous croyez que lui la
conscience de sa connerie ou encore
julien odoul et cyril hanouna qui ont eu
quelques échanges piquant en ligne de la
part d'un pitre qui balance son avis sur
tout donne des leçons à la terre entière
mais ne s'est jamais présentée devant
les électeurs en matière de l'acheter
sheridan n'a fait figure des talons mais
il parle de qui lui j'ai jamais prétendu
vouloir me présenter à une élection
révise tes fiches tu animateur télé et
mon but est juste de divertir et
débattent et frérot pitre saadi plus
depuis 1986 qu'elle sacripant celui ci
quant à mathieu kassovitz il a confondu
twitter avec la salle de boxe pour lui
un tweet égale une patate
yann moix est un petit coup sans honneur
il mérite grandement sa claque dans la
gueule genre la police mais c'est
accidentel
nadine morano je ne suis pas un anonyme
du net mon compte est certifié pourtant
je vous trouve très court peut le dire
aux autres arrêtent de me suivre fils de
l'anonyme il ya quelques jours c'est
karine le marchand qui s'en prenaient à
kelly et mathieu là encore à cause des
positions qu'ils ont pris dans tes pmp
un message posté sur instagram pour le
moins frontale les réseaux sociaux ont
donné le droit à la parole à des légions
dans des styles qui avant de parler
qu'au bar après un verre de vin et ne
causait aucun tort à la collectivité
on les faisait taire tout de suite alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont le même droit de
parole qu'un prix nobel c'est l'invasion
des imbéciles un comportement plutôt
étonnant de la part de ceux qui passent
leur année à faire attention à leur
image
alors ces stars qui s'insultent sur les
réseaux sociaux ridicule ou rigolos
à l'aube à binza alors les ennemis
ridicule ou rigolos moi je peux vous
dire que j'aime ça me fait plus rien
aujourd'hui je sais pas c'est horrible
que ça me passe au dessus rigolo pour
toi sébastien pourquoi balladur on parle
aussi des enfants qui regardent on parle
de non ça peut être rigolo quand quand
le clash est au niveau
maternelle maintenant quand il commence
à y avoir du mépris ou de l'insultent
alors par exemple chez karine lemarchand
j'ai trouvé qu'ils avaient dit qu'il ya
beaucoup de mépris et ça ça me gêne
oui surtout que je pourrai se regarder
et concernant aia nakamura ou mathieu
kassovitz là on est dans l'insultent
donc c'est pas très intéressant non plus
le même sens on peut dire un mot qui est
un petit peu étonnant parce que michael
matthews ça me dérange pas c'est juste
que le lendemain par exemple a dit je ne
veux pas vraiment ma vie privée mais
karine lemarchand que j'aime beaucoup et
c'est nous regarde quand elle est sortie
joey starr est l'ami que des postes
d'elle sur instagram elle avec joey
starr elle en soirée avec joey starr
elle partout et ensuite même quand
c'était fini elle avait dit elle même
elle annonçait la rupture et la
disquette chiant côté une rupture
s'il qu'il faut remplacer la tête de
tous et de toutes les les postes où j'ai
mis mon ex par une couille ce qui était
très drôle
non mais puis en plus c'est bien quand
tu n'as cours on parle de sa vie privée
je ne crois pas à l'étal partout et
quand on est quand on en parle
elle nous insulte non mais en plus ça
mettait des photos de lui dans l'ue au
réveil donc là c'est plus dans le lieu
au réveil c'est plutôt intime il y avait
à faire avec thuram aussi avec thuram
elle avait été s'explique à la
télévision par rapport à leurs problèmes
juridiques
donc est-ce qu'il était aussi assez
intime pour moi donc karine le marchand
c'est une habituée à des clashs elle
avait posté également une vidéo de deux
chatons qui se battent qui ceux qui se
battaient en fait et elle avaient tagué
caris & booba par contre douba et
rentrer dans le lard et là un peul un
peu cassé en disant un retourne voir ton
exquis qui a été inculpé pour violence
sur les femmes et les animaux qu'aux
trouvé ça ridicule vous gras de la
presse people quand même mais en fait
moi aussi je suis plutôt comme c'est
comme ça je peux te trouvais ça rigolo
là où ça me gêne c'est quand excusez-moi
reprendre à voir c'est quand les fans
sont derrière et qu'il confond tout
parce que quand par exemple je vous
donne un exemple récent à y aller comme
moi on s'est compliqué on a juste donné
mon avis par rapport au web à l'émission
et au final j'en ai pris plein la tête
d'al hadhba d'elle des femmes
ouais des trucs hallucinants mais sinon
rien à mes mots qui me touche pas mais
qui n'ont rien à voir avec le débat
ouais mais ça est ce que ça te touche
toi tous
pas du tout nakamura moi le fait qu'elle
skie chaussures dommage c'est que cette
fille une grande carrière elle est très
douée elle commence à être connu dans le
monde entier
c'est pas le souci le moi ce qui m'a
vraiment gêné shaiya nakamura c'est que
quelle m'insulte pourquoi pas mais comme
tu l'as dit après les fans se déchaînent
et quand les fans se déchaînent sa part
dans les trucs horribles ta mère de
surtout dans sa tombe en te voyant
s'allume quand on paie des tout ça alors
qu'on est pas responsable de ce que
disent nos fans
on est responsable quand on les retweets
et chérienne nakamura quand j'ai vu que
tu a retweeté un tweet ou il y avait
juste marquer mathieu et ses petites
copines
sous-entendu vous les [ __ ] doivent bien
danser devant mes chansons pour qu'hypo
qui l'a quand tu retweets à ma fille
en revanche ça c'est pas très bien si tu
veux m'insulter tu m'insultes six jeunes
adultes insultes mais attention ce qu'on
retrouve des papes et ça c'est raser
complètement raison parce que l' inverse
on est elle voudrait taxer de racisme et
ça c'est inadmissible de faire ça parce
que on n'a pas à s'attaquer à ce que
sont les gens dans la vie moi je trouve
ça ridicule ces conflits lançant je
trouve ridicule c'est juste là pour
faire du buzz mais en plus surtout que
c'est le sait notre réseau de la lâcheté
twitter d'accord les gens qui s'en
suivent sur twitter que ça entre deux
stars ou des arts où des anonymes ils
sont derrière leur écran est apparu
quelques harris et booba qui sont
engueulés de rafah et ou pas je me
demande lequel des deux lequel oserait
dire la même chose face à quelqu'un je
déteste ce réseau est la source ce
réseau c'est l'invasion la lâcheté pas
des habitués de la lâcheté mais prônons
de kassovitz tout ça qui parle de bien
loto
votre effort et s attend justement alors
mathieu luc et qu'il juge demande à la
régie le coma il reste deux minutes tu
m'as dit très bien moi je trouve ça
rigolo pour une seule raison c'est que
ces insultes de tous les gens ça permet
de déceler tout de suite les gens qui
sont intelligents complètement con en
gros vous avez eric naulleau par exemple
il s'en sort très bien qu'ils répondent
de manière assez fine aux gens il visait
le contre exemple c'est vikash dhorassoo
où là c'est n'importe quoi c'est à votre
honneur on s'est assis là une autre au
cerveau de la la c'est très vraiment
c'est gênant là c'est gênant mais c'est
tout moi je me rappel au début d'un
grand clash entre ayem et nabila pour
une histoire de haut
il y en avait été le même haut que
l'autre et a duré c'était un truc moi je
regardais avec du recul et je pense
vraiment que les gens qui comme ce qui
s'est passé qui an'a me camara ou au
final comme moi
c'est tout de suite aux énergies les
loups à praia crack amoureuse
[Applaudissements]
c'est con ça y'a que j'aime non plus par
ailleurs je pense qu'au final et les
perdants parce que ce qui ressort c'est
une agressivité gratuite qui dessert ce
que sont les genôts derniers mois chez
des ouais ben rapide rapide luc non
c'est pas gratuit à l'arrêt pour moi je
trouve qu'elle a raison de répondre
aussi bas je trouve quand tu es sur un
plateau télé tu dis elle est ce si elle
est ce là la moins d elle répond elle
répond avec ces mots comme elle veut ça
veut dire petit combiné sur twitter
commandée dans l'est mais mathieu dans
la vie c'est quoi c'est elle et comme
comme il le reconnaissait sa
personnalité c'est une seule personne
qui insulte tout le monde le dit elle
ouvre sa gueule bravo ma fille continue
c'est à gbagbo alors insulte tout le
monde dit lâche toi ya tout ce qui est
en notre attaque mais qu'elle répète je
me suis fait défoncer cette semaine
aussi bravo bats pour ça